I hate to break it to you but if you
call broccoli candy it's still just
broccoli Jen saki who we have not talked
about in a while who was cringe
jean-pierre's predecessor as White House
Press Secretary she then of course you
work for the White House as a paid liar
and then she gets paid even more money
to lie at the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC under the
guise of being a journalist the farce is
just so absolutely incredible you have
to admire it she put out this clip
yesterday talking about abortion and how
Republicans are changing language about
abortion and listen to the way she
describes the pro-life stance this is
this is genuinely disgusting I was
actually like this is like yeah off the
charts go
because they are seeking a Rebrand
pro-life now becomes in the words of
Indiana Senator Todd young pro baby Pro
baby okay I hate to break it to you but
if you call broccoli candy it's still
just broccoli if you tie a really nice
bow around a lump of coal it is still
cool under there I mean she's vile like
I don't even know how to describe that
this has nothing to do with what your
feelings on abortion are
pro-life is pro-baby the pro-life
movement probably should have called it
pro-baby from the beginning I mean this
is a lesson that they should have
learned from the leftists a long time
ago who control language at a much
better capacity than people on the right
do but pro-life you are pro the baby
being born we can have all the arguments
about six weeks 15 weeks the the
difference between the power of the
state and individual choice and the
health of the mother and rape and incest
we can do all of that but pro-life
obviously is pro-baby and and then that
she goes out of her way you have to
understand these people are handed
scripts I have not handed a script we
have we have clips that we play on the
show and I tell you what like what I
think right we discuss it a little bit
beforehand that's it okay but she is
handed a script and they purposely wrote
in there to compare a baby to a lump of
coal like they are just absolutely
terrible